لطالما كانت تقارب الصيني الروسي المتسارع
في السنوات الاخيره تحت مجهر الغرب لكن مع
اشتعال الحرب في اوكرانيا تحولت الريبه
الى مخاوف ثم اتهامات في الذكرى السنويه
الاولى للحرب بان بيجين تستعد لتسليح
موسكو
قد يكون من دعم الصين في مساعي روسيا في
الحرب على اوكرانيا وخاصه بالاسلحه ونراقب
ذلك عن كثب وكما قال الرئيس بايدن خلال
حديثه مع الرئيس الصيني انه سيكون لذلك
انعكاسات على العلاقات بين امريكا والصين
اذا زودت الصين روسيا بالاسلحه في عدوانها
على اوكرانيا او في حال خلقها للعقوبات
الرد على الاتهامات الامريكيه تكفلت به
الخارجيه الصينيه نافيه اياها جمله
وتفصيله
الولايات المتحده وليس الصين هي من يزود
ساحه المعركه بالاسلحه دونما توقف
والولايات المتحده ليست في وضع يسمح لها
باعطاء اوامر للصين ولن نقبل ابدا توجيه
اصابع الاتهام او الاكراه والضغط على
الصين وروسيا لا تكتفي بجيل برد التهم بل
تذهب الى حد التاكيد انها بصدد اصدار ورقه
موقف بشان التسويه السياسيه للحرب في
اوكرانيا تزامنا مع الذكرى السنويه الاولى
لاندلاعها
احتمال تقديم الصين دعما فتاكا لروسيا كما
يقول الامريكيون كان محور النقاش في
اجتماع سابق الاحد بين انطوني بلينكن
ونظيره الصيني في ميونخ على هامش مؤتمر
حول الامن تلك المخاوف سرعان ما تلقفها
الاوروبيون ايضا غداه اجتماعي وزراء
خارجيه الاتحاد في بروكسل
اعربت ان قلقنا الشديد بشان قيام الصين
بتقديم اسلحه لروسيا وطلبت من وانجي عدم
القيام بذلك لم نعبر عن قلقنا فحسب بل عن
حقيقه انه بالنسبه لنا سيكون خطا احمر في
علاقتنا مع الصين
تنام الضغوط الغربيه والامريكيه على الصين
يبدو اقرب الى اجراء استباقي لثنيها عن اي
تعاون عسكري مع الروس بينما تتحدث كيف
وحلفائها عن حسم عسكري خلال العام الحالي
وبالنظر الى ان شراكه بيجين الاقتصاديه
والتجاريه مع اوروبا والولايات المتحده
اكبر بكثير من تلك التي تربطها بموسكو فان
تلك الضغوط هي تذكير لها وتحذير في الان
نفسه من العواقب التجاريه الوخيمه التي قد
تتكبدها في حال اي عقوبات ضدها فهل يضيق
الخناق على الصين فعلا ام ان بمقدورها
دائما ايجاد صيغه الملائمه للحفاظ على
مصالحها مع كل الخصوم مستظله بموقفها
الغامض من الحرب التي امتنعت حتى الان عن
تاييدها او انتقادها